foreign
I lead product management for anthos and
GDC virtual
I'm really excited to talk about anthos
and all the Innovations we are bringing
to help you solve your most pressing
problems help you solve your customers
problems
today we're going to talk about three
things number one what is anthos number
two what's new with anthos and number
three how does anthos power GDC as well
as the capabilities on gcp and
multi-cloud
so let's get started today customers
want a cloud-centric and container-based
operating model everywhere
container adoption continues to expand
rapidly and that means more apps and
infrastructure are being modernized in
more locations
financial services companies are
creating Advanced risk analysis models
retailers are rebuilding e-commerce
platforms and reimagining Retail Edge
applications entertainment companies are
analyzing game statistics in real time
in ballparks and Healthcare companies
are using Advanced AIML to research new
Therapies
this expansion too often leads to more
operations toil for the platform and the
operating it operations team who build
and operate container platforms for the
developers and the application operators
and it's not only expansion outside
public Cloud hybrid and multi-cloud but
growing use of clusters in Google Cloud
as well all these development tests and
production clusters plus all the
different clusters for tens or hundreds
of different workloads either newly
built migrated or modernized from Legacy
can become difficult to configure
monitor secure and optimize
anthos was created to address the
growing demand for hybrid and
multi-cloud solutions for Enterprise
customers
anthos is our cloud-centric platform to
run modern apps anywhere consistently at
scale this means anthos runs on Google
cloud and those runs and other public
clouds such as AWS and Azure and those
runs on premises like data centers it
also runs on premises like Edge
locations stores and restaurants
anthos is the platform that brings all
those pieces together so you can have
one common platform that simplifies your
operations and brings consistent
security and governance across the board
so what problems does antho solve number
one it helps you modernize apps and
infra in place
next it helps you scale large
multi-cluster applications this is one
of the top concerns from customers
who've deployed kubernetes at scale
number three is to bring consistent
governance and Security in all the
environments our customers identify this
as one of their top challenges
what is included as part of anthos right
to start with anthos operates in all the
environments whether it's Google Cloud
on-premises AWS Azure we also have
something called attach clusters we'll
get to that second
next what we want to do is anthos we can
manage all of it the entire cluster
lifecycle management from gcp what this
means is through gcp
you can manage a full cluster lifecycle
Management in any environment
this is what I call kubernetes as a
service
next is kubernetes at scale this is
where you can we help our customers
simplify multi-cluster Automation and
configuration
imagine hundreds and thousands of
clusters how do you manage them how do
you
deliver same consistent governance and
security how do you create Landing zones
for your developers so they can focus on
developing apps and not have to worry
about multiple clusters on top of our
multi-cluster automation is compliance
and governance allows our platform teams
to Define policies whether they are
organizational policies or standard
space policies so you can bring
consistency in every environment next is
to use service mesh to bring micro
segmentation as well as visibility
and third is our operations which means
understanding your performance slas for
your applications whether you're meeting
them or not and then taking the
remediation action to get the slas we
want we also integrate with Doper
experiences and services whether they
are gcp or third party
we'll talk more about it in the later
slides
so now that we know what anthos is all
about let's talk about what's new with
anthos
all right so first we made it simpler
easier and has less friction
number two
now we are delivering consistency at
scale meaning multiple clusters helping
your developers focus on dropping apps
and not the infrastructure and number
three now we can expand anthos and GDC
through your retail Edge locations
so let's start with the first one and do
a deeper dive
first
it's a fully hosted gcp service that
allows full cluster lifecycle management
no matter where you run meaning your
clusters can be running on gcp your
clusters can be running on-prem your
clusters can be running on AWS Azure or
other public cloud
you can manage those clusters directly
through gcp either through our consoles
or through our gcloud it's a fantastic
way to automate this it's a fantastic
way to bring more
capabilities to from an operations
perspective
next is the attached clusters remember
we talked about this before so if you
already have kubernetes deployed in
other clouds or other environments using
other kubernetes orchestration or
platforms and you want to bring the same
consistency and same anthos solutions to
those clusters what do you do
simple way is to attach those clusters
into anthos what we call attached
clusters what that means is that once
you attach them into anthos takes few
minutes then you can apply same policies
you can bring the same observability you
can also bring the same Fleet like
capabilities to all those clusters it's
a fantastic way to get started sooner
and delivering value sooner to your Dev
teams
next single piano class everyone wants
this we have it right number one from
anthos on gcp you can see all your
clusters no matter where they are you
can do a deeper dive into them get
better visibility
right so that's enough about how we made
it simpler let's talk about how we help
you scale this is our number one ask
from our customers how do I scale how do
I scale how do I scale right so we are
delivering a lot of innovation to help
you get there number one
why do customers end up creating
multiple clusters as a number of they
want to create a large operating
environment
and once they create that large
operating environment they can create
different tenancies each tenancy
within the same operating fabric made up
of multiple clusters
this is something that we call
multi-cluster management via fleets now
what does this allow you to do right
number one you can create different
Tendencies you can apply the same set of
security to all those clusters meaning
now your Dev teams don't have to worry
about figuring out how to secure them
your platform team can apply the same
policies to every cluster as soon as
they apply to a fleet all the Clusters
get the same set of policies same
security configurations
so what does anthos multi-classure
management we actually do number one
visibility all your clusters across the
entire fleet you can get the key status
and configuration information number two
it's as simple to connect into a fleet
go in there connect voila done
third you can start assigning different
features let's say you want a common
config management across all of them
let's say you want to apply the same
service mesh capabilities to all of them
number three you could also do common
identity Services you can deploy Cloud
build and Cloud deploy as well
this makes it super powerful simplifies
the management across multiple clusters
this is our brand new dashboard for
Fleet or multi-cluster capabilities it
helps you Fleet right visibility for
your container infrastructure across all
your environments
includes key information about resource
utilization infrastructure policy
violations it also integrates with Cloud
Ops for deep analysis and alerting
compliance and governance once you
define your policies either standards
based or based on your own uh
organizational policies the dashboard
allows you to get quick visibility into
which policy violations are there
whether they're in audit mode or they're
in enforcement mode it helps you better
understand how what you need to do to
remediate and get back into compliance
that
is something we are super excited about
a lot of our customers this has been our
number one ask from our customers
right now let's talk about expansion to
the retail Edge who's excited about this
I am all of our customers are they want
to deploy anthos to retail Edge because
this allows them to fundamentally
transform the retail Edge right it helps
them bring personalized offers worker
safety without having to replace their
existing store infrastructure how good
is that right so what what are our
customers trying to solve for number one
well it's not easy right let's start
with that number one the app deployment
cycle is long there is limited
operational visibility at scale imagine
hundreds thousands of locations there
are multiple failure Dimensions you hear
things like someone by mistake not the
power cable and down goes the
infrastructure
you have other things like you have a
heterogeneous mixed infrastructure you
have applications that were built to run
on VMS you have app modern applications
that are designed to run on containers
can't have multiple platforms you need
one way to manage all of that
to the anthos powering GDC virtual helps
you solve those challenges number one
through anthos you can deploy fast and
secure applications across the board you
get up unified operational visibility
you get resilient architecture meaning
if you lose connectivity
or if you have limited connectivity your
application still continue to work
meaning you still get to deliver value
to your customers and number three it
leverages your existing infrastructure
and Hardware Partnerships that you might
have
to do this we've recently delivered
anthos for VM it's a unified
cloud-backed management for containers
and VMS so what does this really mean
right imagine a deployment where you've
got your modern applications but you
have some third-party apps that are not
going to be containerized what do you do
anthos allows you to migrate those apps
to anthos for VM and now you have a
common platform to manage both of those
number one it provides a unified Dev and
Ops experience for your VMS and
containers number two it's a developer
self-service provisioning of VMS it's a
declarative deployment model for
simplified devops it provides the same
policy enforcement for consistent
compliance
we also have a tool that we deliver that
allows you to quickly determine whether
that VM based app will work on the
anthos for VM runtime or not
so that is amazing amount of uh
Innovation that we are delivering and
I'm super excited about it so how does
anthos power all of this stuff on GDC
and gcp it's a lot of stuff going on
right so number one
Google's anthos helps bring Cloud
operating model everywhere whether
you're on gcp whether in Azure AWS or on
Google distributed Cloud anthos Powers
both of those it gives you common
control plane it brings container
orchestration and management across both
of them it brings common policy and
security Automation and it brings
operations in service management
and those Powers GDC in three ways
number one is Google distributed Cloud
for the edge this is where Google
delivers a managed hardware and software
solution designed for low latency and
data resiliency and hybrid workloads
number two
and GDC virtual this is our software
only solution that works on your
hardware and your OS
it's great for retail Edge it's great
for environments where you want to
leverage your existing Hardware
Investments and the third one is a
completely air gap solution called
Google distributed Cloud hosted
on gcp and multi-cloud answers Powers
three ways number one anthos runs on gcp
right it delivers an integrated solution
that brings together gke Fleet Service
mesh policy configuration and security
on gcp number two anthos on multi-cloud
it brings together Google's kubernetes
Fleet Service mesh all the other
capabilities we talked about to AWS and
azure
and finally anthos attached clusters
it's our it allows our customers to
attach their existing clusters into
anthos so you can take advantage of our
service mesh policy configuration and
security for your all your existing
kubernetes clusters
so to recap anthos is our cloud-centric
container platform to run modern apps
anywhere consistently at scale meaning
it runs on Google Cloud it runs on other
public clouds it runs on premises Data
Center and it runs on your Edge
we are delivering
three key Innovations number one we've
made it simpler and easier number two we
are delivering consistency at scale I
think hundreds of clusters or thousands
and antos now expands to retail Edge
thank you so much for your time I'm
super excited with all the innovations
that we have I'm super excited to help
you innovate and deliver new
capabilities to your customer
thank you so much for your time
[Music]